PETER DYKSTRA: Hey, everyone.
My name is Peter, and I'm part
of the AppSheet product team
here at Google Cloud.
Thanks for joining this
session about how to build AI
powered no-code
apps with AppSheet.
I personally work on making
AppSheet as accessible
as possible for
business users that
don't have coding experience
to build apps with AppSheet.
And I'm joined by
my teammate, Tony,
who is a senior engineer
focused on building AI
into the platform to
make it easier to use,
as well as into the end
applications that people
can create to make those apps
themselves really powerful.
Thanks for joining, Tony.
TONY FADER: Hey, Peter.
Thanks.
So today we're going to walk
through the basics of how
to build an application
without writing code in order
to digitize a common
business process.
After we do that, we're
going to look at a few ways
to make the app intelligent and
even more efficient by adding
machine learning to it.
PETER DYKSTRA: Great.
So for a little background,
a real serious challenge
that many businesses face
is this growing demand
for improving their
internal technology,
but they frequently lack
the skills and resources
to update and build those
solutions internally.
Software that comes
out of the box
rarely meets all the
unique requirements
that a business has, as
developing custom solutions
becomes necessary real quickly.
But it's expensive,
it's time-consuming,
and frequently just
doesn't get done.
There just aren't
enough developers
to help tackle all the
opportunities for updating
and modernizing the process.
TONY FADER: Yeah.
And it's even harder to use AI
and machine learning to make
your business workflow smarter.
The skill sets for
these are rare.
It involves unique
infrastructure
for building your applications,
and configuring these things
just takes tons of time.
And so this is just overhead
that most organizations
don't have.
So intelligent no-code
platforms help solve this
by enabling anyone to
be that app developer AI
expert, no matter what
their background is.
So machine learning baked
into the no-code platform
helps in three ways.
First, it makes
app creation easier
for the user by guiding them
along the common pathways.
Second, it makes the apps
themselves more powerful
and efficient by, say,
automatically doing
data entry for you.
And third, it makes governance
even easier and more reliable
in the long term.
So no-code apps can
include all sorts
of powerful
functionality, including
collecting or managing
data more efficiently,
automating business workflows,
and sharing insights
with teammates, taking
advantage of things
like business intelligence
with dashboards, charts,
and reports.
PETER DYKSTRA: Yeah.
There's opportunity
for creating apps
that use features
like those really all
throughout an organization.
It could be out in the
field with customers.
It could be managing projects.
It could be like manufacturing
or distribution facilities,
or in the office in a
more corporate setting.
But some of the most
valuable opportunities
are with desk-less workers.
So these teammates
don't necessarily
sit behind a computer
during the day.
They're more likely to
experience friction trying
to collaborate with
other teammates
or access important
information just in order
to do their job effectively.
So let's look at this
example of how to get
started building a
no-code application that
helps a manufacturing team
perform quality control
inspections more efficiently
from their mobile devices.
Specifically, let's
digitize their inspections,
taking it from a pen and
paper process to a mobile app.
And then Tony can
help take that app
and make it even more
efficient by building
a machine learning model into
it with just a few steps.
So how do you get started?
To start the process, you're
connecting a data source
to AppSheet to serve as the
back end of that application.
Then we'll define an
interface and behavior
of that app in AppSheet before
we share it with the team.
Once it's in the
hands of end users,
those updates that they're
making in the application
get synced right back to
that original data source.
So let's open up
AppSheet and get started
building this particular app.
In order to get
this app started,
we want to make
sure that we have
the data source ready to go.
In this case, we're going
to use a Google Sheet here,
and this Google Sheet
has three tables.
We have some recent
inspection data,
we have the parts that
are being inspected,
and we also have
the employees that
are performing the inspections.
So let's connect
this to AppSheet
to get this app started.
We're going to
connect to Google,
and we're going to find this
particular Google Sheet.
And AppSheet's going to connect
to that initial inspections
table.
Then we'll want to connect
to the other two as well.
While it's connecting
to those tables, what's
happening behind the
scenes is that it's
looking at the
content of that data
and then building a relevant
prototype automatically
based on what it can find.
And so you can see we already
have an application here
that allows for creating
new inspections for viewing
those existing
ones, and then also
viewing the inspections
on a calendar based
on the dates in that data.
Let's connect the other
two tables, and then
let's customize this interface.
With these three
tables connected now,
one thing that AppSheet was
doing also behind the scenes
was intelligently
building relationships
between the tables based
on what it could find,
based on the fields that it's
looking at in these tables.
And so because we
have a relationship--
there are employees
performing the inspections,
and the inspections are being
performed on different parts--
there's going to
be relationships
between this data,
and that's already
represented in this
prototype of the application.
If we look at one of
these inspections,
you can see that the part
itself has been connected
and I can navigate
to the part details.
When I'm looking
at this part, it
has related inspections that
have been performed on it.
I can also see the
employee who performed
this particular inspection.
I can go to that
employee's details.
So with these
relationships established,
that just gives me
a huge head start
on what type of functionality I
can expose in the application,
and it makes it a lot
easier then to now customize
the app to be exactly what
I want for my end users.
If I move into the
UX section, you
can see that there were a
few different views created,
but I want this
application to be fairly
straightforward and simple.
So I'm going to go ahead and
remove a couple of these views,
and I'm going to customize
the inspections view
and make sure that there is a
dedicated form view to create
new inspection entries.
You can see
throughout the editor
there are going to be
suggestions for what features
and what elements might be
helpful in your application.
In this case, when I'm
looking at the view types,
I have an automatic view
type that has been selected.
I'd like to take advantage
of these images that
are being collected from
these inspection cards.
So I'm going to use the
card view, actually,
to better highlight
those images.
What's advantageous
about this card view
is that it provides
a really easy way
of defining which fields get
exposed in the app interface.
And so here, I'm just
going to go through some
of these different fields.
Maybe I want to show the
employee and the date
of their inspection up top.
And then the main image
is already selected.
And then I really want to
highlight whether or not
this inspection was
accepted or rejected,
and so I'll make that
the primary header.
And then I want to make sure
that, if it is rejected,
the description of that
inspection gets highlighted.
Now, I can include
actions in this view
to help navigate or
initiate workflows.
I'm going to remove those
so it's nice and clean.
And so now I have a
view here on the right
showing those existing
inspections that
have been performed that I'm
starting this application with.
Last step here is, because
these are inspection cards,
I'll put a relevant
view icon of a card.
And I'd like, alongside this,
a quick way for my application
users to perform
new inspections.
When creating this
view, I'm going
to make sure that it is
adding new inspections
to the inspections table.
I'm going to make this a form.
And then I'll make this form
icon something relevant,
like a magnifying
glass and a plus sign.
Great.
So now this application
consists of two primary views--
a way of adding new inspections,
and a way of viewing existing
inspections.
I'm going to go ahead
and save this app.
I want to make sure the app
logo is very relevant so my app
users recognize the application.
And then, because an important
part of this application
is really quickly
identifying inspections
that have been
rejected, I'm going
to add a format rule
that just calls attention
to rejected inspections.
So in this case, I'm going
to say, for every inspection
where the condition
equals rejected,
I'm going to apply a format
to that particular condition
field.
And in this case, I want a--
let's see-- little alert, and
I want the text to be red.
And you can already
see here on the right
that we're previewing
that effect.
So I'll go ahead and save this.
Great.
So now I'll open this
application up and preview it
in tablet form.
And you can get a better sense
for how those inspections that
have been logged
by my employees are
visible and readily accessible.
And I can also very
quickly get to the details
of the different employees
and see inspections
that they have performed,
or, for example,
look at different parts
that are being manufactured
and see related inspections.
So one reason why this
is valuable to employees
is that it's
digitizing the process,
and it's making this
information more
reliably accessible long term.
Another really important
part of this application
is getting the information into
the hands of the right people
more quickly than
it previously did.
So one way that we
can support that is
by building a workflow
in order to notify
the right person
or the right team
as soon as an inspection
has been logged as rejected.
So in this case, let's
build a workflow that
sends a notification email
to the right contact whenever
a new inspection has been logged
that meets this condition.
In this case, we're
going to continue
looking at that
inspections table,
and we're going to say that
every time a new row has been
added and the condition
equals rejected,
we're going to send an email,
and we'll send this email
to the operations team.
And we'll want a
relevant email subject.
And then we can actually
use a Google Doc
as the template for this email.
So on the side here,
I've created a Google Doc
that is just a simple
layout that includes some
of the fields from my app data.
I can use this as a template
for this particular email.
And so if I include a link
to that template, every time
this workflow will run, it
will draw from that template
and send an email formatted
based on that Google Doc
layout.
Great.
Now let's test what happens
when we add a new inspection
to this application.
We can use a photo of a
recently inspected tag that's
come off one of the parts.
This part has been
marked as rejected,
and I'll fill in some
of the details here.
Submitting a form
in an AppSheet app
passes that data right through
to the connected data source.
So in this case, it's going to
add a row to the Google Sheet,
and that added row
triggers the workflow
that will send the email
notification to the team.
So at this point, the app is
ready to start being used,
and I can get it to
the team by sending
individual email invites.
I can invite just a group
from my organization,
or I can make it accessible
to the entire domain,
and then I can
share a link that is
accessible by any user
on their mobile device
or on their desktop.
OK.
So we've got the foundation
of this app created,
and it's already ready
for the team to be using.
So they can capture their
inspections digitally instead
of just with pen and paper.
So they're already using an app.
They're already collecting these
tickets in the application.
The real gains from
this particular app
are going to come by
incorporating this AI model,
specifically using some
of that existing data
to build an OCR model.
So, Tony, can you walk us
through that stage right now?
TONY FADER: So Peter
just talked about how
to build this cool
quality control
app that allows you to move
from a paper-based process
to a digital process where,
instead of employees filling
out paper forms, they're
using this mobile app to take
pictures of these tickets and
transcribe the information.
So what I'm going
to talk about next
is how to take advantage of
the data that is now being
collected via this mobile app.
So you can think of every time
an employee uses this app, they
take a photo of one of these
quality control tickets
and then enters in information.
So we're building up a data set.
Now we can use AI
and machine learning
to take advantage of the
data that we've collected
and further enrich the
app by making it more
efficient and easier to use.
So let me give you a quick
tour of some of the AI features
that are available in AppSheet.
So I'm going to navigate
to the Intelligence tab
in the AppSheet editor,
and the first feature
I want to show you is the
smart assistant feature.
So the smart assistant feature
enables a Google Assistant-like
experience inside
of your mobile app,
but customized to
your business domain.
So once you flip the
switch in the editor,
you get your own
custom assistant that
understands natural language.
Let me give you a
couple examples.
So to access the Assistant,
I go to this view that's
available on the side menu
of my app called Assistant,
and here I can do
things like this.
Can you show me the
inspections from last month?
So the Assistant takes
my question like this
and understands it in terms
of the data and concepts that
are in my app.
Can you show me just
the rejected ones?
So you can see
that it understood
what I said and further
filtered the data down
to just the rejected
inspections.
Can you show me more information
about the rotary piston?
So this is just
a couple examples
of the types of interactions
you could have with the Smart
Assistant feature in AppSheet.
Now I'd like to show you
AppSheet's OCR, or Optical
Character Recognition, features.
So let's go back to
the inspection data
that we've been collecting.
So you can see I've got
a quality control ticket
image taken with
a mobile device,
and then I've got the
information that we've
transcribed down below.
So in our current
process, the employee
needs to both take
a photo and then
manually transcribe the
information from the ticket.
I'm going to show
you how you can
use OCR to automate this
process and go directly
from a picture of
one of these tickets
and have a filled out form based
on the content from the image
itself.
So this OCR feature leverages
Google Cloud Vision API.
This means that
business users have
access to the same powerful
machine learning algorithms
that were traditionally limited
to software engineers before.
So let me walk you
through the steps
that you need to take in
order to add this type of OCR
capability to the AppSheet app.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is create a new OCR model.
So what an OCR model
is is it's a way
of looking at the
examples of the data
that we've already collected
and coming up with a machine
learning model that
can then extract
from new images
that haven't been
seen in the data set before.
So the first thing I need
to do is choose my table.
In this case, I'm going to
choose the inspections table,
because that's the data
that I want to use this on
to go from the picture
of an inspection ticket
to these extracted fields.
Next, I need to specify
the image column.
In this case, there's
just a single column
in my data set called image.
This is going to be
the input to the model.
Then I choose the output.
These are the
columns in the data
set that I want to predict.
In this case, it's
automatically selected
the other columns in the table,
like condition, part number,
quantity, and so on.
So this is how I
specify the model.
And when I press save,
what's going to happen is--
actually, it's going to
look at the data that's
already in my table--
these examples you see
over here on the right--
and it's going to use a
machine learning model
to figure out common patterns
of where these values appear
in the images.
So I'm going to press Save.
Cool.
Now that the page is reloaded,
the OCR model has been trained,
and we can actually
inspect it to see what
it learned from the data set.
So I'm going to scroll
down a little bit.
And you can see
here below my model,
I have the examples
from my training set.
If I click on them,
you can see that it's
found out where in the image the
columns in my table are found.
So for example, this yellow
piece right here at the bottom
is identified as where
the description is
located in the image.
And it identified that
the word rejected up
here corresponds to
the condition field
in the same table.
So it's gone through
these 10 or so examples
that we've already collected
in regular use of the app
and figured out how
to generalize from it,
and now we can use it to
identify where these fields are
automatically new images.
So let me give you
an example of that.
So I'm going to go
back to the app here,
and I'm going to click on
the New Inspection button
at the bottom.
So you can see this is the
form that the app creators have
been using to fill
out the app so far.
So now I'm going to upload
a new image to the form.
This is an image that
wasn't already on the table.
So the app hasn't
seen this before.
So I've selected
the image, and I
can see that it's automatically
filled out the rest of the form
with values from the image.
So for example, I've got
the date as July 26, 2020
from the upper-right-hand
corner of the image.
So you can see, once you start
using AppSheet to digitize
your paper-based
processes, you start
getting compounding returns.
Once you collect
the data set, it
becomes more valuable because
you can use AI and machine
learning algorithms on it.
However, you don't have to be
an expert to use them anymore.
We provide no-code
interfaces to it
that allow business users
to create their custom
machine learning models for
their particular business
domain.
These algorithms are built
on top of Google Cloud AI
features.
So you get the same powerful
machine learning capabilities
that were traditionally only
available to train software
engineers, but now
you can access them
without writing any code at all.
PETER DYKSTRA: Great.
Thanks, Tony.
So in 15 minutes, we've
digitized this inspection
process with a custom app
that uses ML models built in,
built from existing
business data.
And what we've shown can really
be built by anyone on the team
who sees an
opportunity to innovate
and who understands
how to improve
this particular process.
So, Tony, I'd like
to just expand
on a few topics that are
related to what we just showed.
The first is, I'm curious--
based on this application
and where it is right now,
where do you think would
be some natural next steps
to take it to extend
the functionality
for this particular scenario?
TONY FADER: Yeah.
So one thing I didn't
talk about my demo
was AppSheet's
predictive models.
So predictive models allow you
to automatically categorize
records based on the data
that you've collected so far.
So for example, in this
inspection ticketing scenario,
what you could do is have
the platform automatically
categorize these tickets
based on the words that
appear in the description.
You can then use
that categorization
to route failures and
rejections to the right team.
So this is another
way that you can
use Cloud AI-powered machine
learning without having
to be a programmer.
PETER DYKSTRA: Great.
Yeah.
So in the example that
we just showed, and then
also the extension that
you just described,
is there a particular
example of a customer that
has built a similar solution
and is using it with their team
that you can describe
a little bit?
TONY FADER: Yeah.
So as an example,
we've got a customer
from the construction
industry who is starting
to roll out an OCR-powered app.
So what they have is an
AppSheet-powered workflow
already where they have truck
drivers driving, picking up
goods and delivering
them to work sites.
And every time
they do this, they
have to use their mobile phone
to take a picture of a trucking
ticket or a receipt.
They're already using an
AppSheet app to do this,
and then a QA person downstream
goes through those images
that the truck drivers captured
and manually transcribes
all the information
from the shipment weight
to the date and the time.
But because they already
have this workflow built
on an AppSheet app,
they're able to just extend
it further using the
platform's OCR capabilities.
So now the QA person
doesn't have to go through
and transcribe
every ticket, which
would take minutes
for every ticket,
and they have hundreds
of these tickets.
Now they can just actually have
the OCR system automatically
fill out the forms,
and then they
can just verify to
make sure it's correct.
So this just saves tons of
time for these QA people.
PETER DYKSTRA: Yeah, very cool.
Thanks, Tony.
So finally, can you just give us
a quick synopsis or description
of what is around the corner
for AI in the AppSheet platform?
TONY FADER: Yeah.
So there's a couple of
things I can highlight.
So one is the platform itself
is becoming more and more
intelligent, giving app
creators suggestions
as they build their app, making
it easier to go from an idea
to a fully-functioning app.
A second way that
we're improving things
is allowing you
to build workflows
based on cloud AI technology.
So for example,
having a workflow
where you upload
a document that's
automatically categorized,
routed to the right person,
and classified for them.
And a third direction
is deeper integrations
with Google Cloud's
machine learning offerings
to make it even easier
for apps to understand
your own structured data.
PETER DYKSTRA: That's great.
Thanks for sharing, Tony.
It's real exciting
to see sort of how
the platform, the apps
themselves are continuing
to get new AI features.
So just to recap what
Tony has described
and what we've shown here
in these couple demos
is having AI built
into the no-code apps
as well as into the
authoring environment,
it really just boils down
to apps being easier to make
and being capable of really
powerful functionality.
And really importantly,
all along the way,
because this is entirely
in a no-code environment,
it's really easy to control
with organizational level
policies that are
real simple to set up,
and they're easy to
maintain long term.
So with that, thank you,
Tony, for your work,
making this functionality
available, and for helping
demonstrate it today.
And thank you, everyone
who has joined the session
and are watching this video.
I know I speak for
the team when I
say that we're excited to have
new users joining and creating
real interesting and powerful
solutions for their own teams.
There's a real strong
community of app creators
here at AppSheet and
throughout Google,
and honestly, all
over the world that
are ready to help share
ideas and help you get
started in the platform.
So if you'd like to learn
more and try it out,
you can find AppSheet
in Google Cloud
or directly at AppSheet.com.
Thanks.